ladies and gentlemen i bring you to time
magazine
saying the quiet part loud no not
actually i i take that back
we'll explain the secret history of the
shadow campaign
that saved the 2020 election
no joke i'm tracking straight up
they say trump was right there was
okay i am reading i'm gonna read to you
from time magazine
trump was right there was a conspiracy
unfolding behind the scenes
one that both curtailed the protests and
coordinated the resistance from ceos
both surprises were the result of an
informal alliance between left-wing
activists
and business titans the democrats
major corporations and ceos formed what
i guess you could call a
lucrative merger between corporation and
state for the purpose of winning
political power
is there a word for something like that
the word's fascist oh fascists
oh is that is that the word let's just
cut to the chase yeah
okay i was just about to swear don't do
it
the handshake between business and labor
was just one component
of a vast cross-partisan campaign but
the best part is
just just jumping down because they
really are quite
wordy in this let me read this for you
yeah no kidding this is the inside story
of the
conspiracy to save the 2020 election
based on access to the group's inner
workings
never before seen documents and
interviews with dozens of those involved
from across the political spectrum
i'm gonna stop right there and tell you
that conspiracy implies a crime
in in in law it does and the general
definition is
unlawful or harmful act a group acting
in secret
for an unlawful or harmful outcome
they go on to say it is the story of an
unprecedented creative and determined
campaign
whose success also reveals how close the
nation came to disaster
every attempt to interfere with the
proper outcome of the election was
defeated
the proper outcome of the election
interesting words what does that mean i
love this article
i love everything about this article i
love it the way it's written a
huge molly ball right yeah i want to buy
her dinner
wow i love it uh uh but they say quote
but it's massively important for the
country to understand that it didn't
happen
accidentally the system didn't work
magically democracy is not
self-executing
that's why the participants want the
secret history of the 2020 election told
even though it sounds like a paranoid
fever dream a well-funded
okay i'm gonna stop right now my friends
i am reading you
verbatim from time.com time magazine
these are not my words
a well-funded cabal of powerful people
ranging across industries and ideologies
working together behind the scenes to
influence perceptions
change rules and laws steer media
coverage
and control the flow of information they
were not
rigging the election they were
fortifying it and they believe the
public needs to understand the system's
fragility
in order to ensure that democracy in
america endures
i'll make it very clear for you you are
not saving democracy when you conspire
behind the scenes
with powerful industrialists ceos and
the elites
to subvert the flow of information and
prevent
the the improper outcome as so you as as
you see it
the true outcome is to sit back advocate
for your candidate advocate for your
ideas
and then hope people vote for you what
they did
very much sounds like it was criminal
and i'll tell you why
many i believe that the number right now
is 24 states
changed their election rules without
going through state legislatures
now illegal is very different statutory
law is different from constitutional law
so
i shouldn't say criminal i'll just put
it this way it was
a conspiracy to violate the constitution
to stop donald trump from winning
to steer media coverage control the flow
of information
change rules and laws prior to an
election just as our founding fathers
that's right created for i remember it
was uh
it was uh who who was it uh who said
give me liberty or give me death patrick
so he was this was in virginia and they
were having you know this in house
delegates
yes yes yes and they were trying to
determine whether to join the revolution
and he stood up and said
give me liberty well asterisks will come
back to that or give me death now what i
meant by that was
we want to make sure the rabble can't be
in control of these elections you know
so we as the powerful elites want to
actually manipulate them into thinking
they have the power and
give me that and then maybe i'm willing
to die for it that's exactly how it went
fortifying is also a very interesting
word here and also the timing
why now did time and i want to say this
too
admit that there was a secret cabal of
powerful wealthy elites that were
working with corporations steering media
coverage influence perceptions and
changing their rules to get their way
time said that not me don't get me in
trouble why now
did this happen and when you look at
those kind of other statements you're
seeing some rebuttals here and the
rebuttals here
rebuttals here are that it was done in
public there was this was sort of
transparent but but
even if it was it still doesn't make it
a good thing
and when we look at what actually
happened this election specifically with
the hunter biden story especially with
some of the primaries
in the democratic uh you know
presidential run up
you see a lot of foul playing you see a
lot of things that shouldn't have
happened
but did and they're wrong the hunter
biden cover-up story that's the biggest
one
and and to what you're saying and we
want to be clear about this because the
article does this as well
and even with something we'll talk about
later the timeline matters right going
through the timeline this article is
important because they don't lay this
out in a chronological fashion
you get about three quarters of the way
through this article i've read it twice
it's about 6 500 words
and about three quarters of the way
through
they admit that this was something they
were working on in october
and november of 2019 because remember
we're all told we were all sold on this
well we had to do changes we had to
change the system because of covet 19.
forget the fact that dr fauci actually
came out and berks came out
and said oh you actually can safely vote
in person they said that
as long as you're doing this social
distancing six feet you're wearing a
mask
perfectly fine same as you know going to
walmart anyways it is obviously an
essential
uh an essential act that you want to be
performing so dr fauci came out and said
that
but no no we were told now this it can't
be done the workers have to be there all
day
we can't allow this to happen we've got
to do the mail-in voting we've got to do
universal voting
send ballots everywhere ballots all over
the place in many of these states
and they were planning to do this even
before the word
covid crossed anyone's lips in the west
back when even before china started
arresting the physicians out in wuhan
right they were already planning to
change the system to get
what they said the appropriate outcome
proper
the problem uh the mainland voting
change
in pennsylvania happened in october of
october yeah well before cove it
happened and i remember i didn't i
didn't realize that
and so i saw this lawsuit pop up and
then i started researching and i was
like wait
wait they passed mail-in voting in
october i thought mail-in voting was
being passed because of covid
no it was part of a elite cabal
plan according to time magazine and they
actually say this mail in voting to get
people to vote for by mail for the first
time
it was part of their plan now i'll be
i'll be honest
i mean we knew this i have how many
videos where i said the democrats are
rigging the election
and what i said was they're not doing
anything they're changing the rules
at the last minute in order to benefit
themselves we had sean parnell on the
show and he said
they're changing the rules because it's
going to help them win
so it's funny you could say they broke
the rules but they changed the rules
beforehand
so no rules were actually broken except
maybe the constitution which is a big
rule
but the problem with that with that is
that the court cases all got through on
either
standing or latches so i made a mistake
on twitter i said that
the the uh vote by mail rule was
unconstitutional at the state and
federal level
and it was a lower court judge said that
the the plaintiffs so this is sean
parnell and i think mike kelly
would have won on the merit uh that
mail-in voting is not
allowed universally in pennsylvania
because they have rules about how
you know you can do absentee ballots
it's our state constitution right right
right
but it got sent to the higher court the
state supreme court
who threw it out not on the merit but on
latches right which means
you filed this lawsuit way too late it's
over goodbye right so here's here's the
catch-22 on all of that and i say this
as
i i'm you know pennsylvania kid
philadelphia area
that so the pennsylvania state supreme
court right now is currently controlled
by a super majority of democrats
and what they did was they were saying
okay doctrine of latches that means
too much time has gone by we can't fix
this
therefore there's no way to actually uh
remunerate what's been done to you and
so we're going to have to let this slide
there's no way to redo the election it's
kind of what they're saying
but at sean parnell's point i've spoken
with him on this as well
had he brought that case prior to the
election
they would say you do not have standing
because you have yet
to be injured exactly so if the catch 22
becomes
you can't have you can't file suit prior
you can't file suit
after when are you supposed to do it in
the middle of the day on election day it
doesn't make
any sense and you've written this in
such a way where
you this is and this is why people love
lawyers so much that
you know you've cut you've created a
situation where there is no way to find
relief from this
they could they here's what they need
they need to do they needed to have sued
immediately
and then when they said you have no
injury then they could have sued and
said ah look at that one
and that would have at least been their
leg to stand on we tried you said
standing we now have injury we're back
and then they would have to be like oh
well they can't cite latches because i
already tried suit and now that we're
injured
however they might have said that they
may they probably would have said the
same thing oh well it's been a year
now so it's too long the law has been
put in place blah blah
i want to read something to you guys
from the article this is the craziest
the craziest aspect of this
which i think is one of the most
demoralizing sentences you'll probably
hear
their work touched every aspect of the
election they got states to change
voting systems
and laws and helped secure hundreds of
millions in public and private funding
you ready for the next one they fended
off voter suppression laws
well i'm sorry they fended off voter
suppression lawsuits
recruited armies of poll workers and got
millions of people to vote by mail for
the first time
i would like to see an investigation
into what that sentence means
what do you mean they recruited poll
workers they were poll workers who were
in
this cabal in this conspiracy according
time magazine let me slow it down for
you guys
time magazine said there was a
conspiracy to
uh to produce the proper outcome they
recruited
poll workers it's in the article i'm
going to show you one more time it says
they recruited armies of poll workers
what were they doing
what were those poll workers doing as
part of this conspiracy where's what are
the sources of this
article they have the names they have
the people on record everyone's named on
record
there's from the afl-cio uh the not the
president but the senior adviser to the
president
there's people involved from numerous
progressive leftist center organizations
um a ton of people from these you know
protect democracy type groups like norm
eisen
ian bessen is someone who has also been
named in there a lot of the same people
by the way
who were pushing the russia gate
lawsuits
running a lot of the websites that had
to do with russiagate i mean all those
ones that sort of started bubbling up in
around
late 2017 early 2018 suddenly shifted
mueller came out that didn't work the
report they shifted suddenly and then
starting in 2019
they were all talking about this
election
uh what they called protection voter
protection
right and again to use that phrase
there's a lot of editorializing in this
article as well and i hope people
understand that while they're reading
this that
they call it an election suppression law
well an election suppression law if you
have a different perspective on it it
might be something called
an election integrity law election right
having somebody check your signature
doing a signature match that's not
suppression
they call it suppression that's not
that's making sure that
that's the real person that's actually
signing up checking id this is not
suppression this is making sure you are
the real person
but they will call it suppression as a
way of saying oh you're trying to
disenfranchise people no
we are trying to make sure that election
look i'm a veteran a lot of people are
veterans we always talk about
our democracy is the most important
thing in this country well shouldn't we
take it seriously and not allow
shadowy cabals to be able to come in and
control the flow of information and laws
so so editorializing right
they come out they say voter suppression
and disinformation disinformation
literally just means
information from your perspective you
could say it's fake news someone else
could say it's not
it's literally suppressing just
information whether you like it or not
it could be disinformation sure i'm not
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you